normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government we got
this from Bloomberg Yaro the pizza gate
Pizzeria oh no no no let's talk about
this story yakin's memo to ex-staff
calls musk candid and profound I love
this uh long story short the CEO has
doubled down when they announced that
Linda Yaro was going to be the CEO
everybody thought okay here we go WF you
know deep State whatever she's going to
start Banning people instead when Elon
Musk says go off yourself she puts out a
statement being like no we stand by this
and we believe in it and we will not be
bullied into changing our position
because people are trying to hold money
from take money from us here's the best
part I see these lefties on Twitter
mocking her for doing this being like
haha look at her she's pushing this this
interview out more and I'm like I think
that's a great test to expose who the
grifters are because these leftists who
are saying that what they're telling us
is that in their worldview they're
saying why why would you want to lose
money whereas Elon is saying take all
the money from me I'm not backing down
from what I believe is right so it shows
you where we are where they are not
everybody on the left I'm just saying
the ones that are saying that you're
saying the sort of this sentiment is
like well you're screwing your career
but without any talk of do they actually
think that yeah so when when I see these
lefties be like haha why would you why
would you push this further you know
they're basically saying why would you
announce an ideological position that
would jeopardize your business and it's
really funny because to me I'm on the
other side I'm like I absolutely will
tell an Advertiser to screw off if they
tried to do that I think Elon Musk
doesn't do anything unless he sees a
long-term gain right so he wouldn't
announce these positions publicly if he
didn't think that they were worth it and
I think that's the the measure that
culture is Shifting I mean even with
Yaro the thing that she got in trouble
for was that she was saying Twitter we
like Free Speech but we will de amplify
hateful content and de amplify was like
a specific word about you know people
get afraid of like being Shadow band or
whatever and for her to have fallen in
line with a more musk es position is
interesting shifts within the cuz he's
the boss but I don't think elon's
playing 5D chess I think he's just
pissed and he's the richest man in the
world so he can tell anybody who wants
to f off rich man in the world why does
he care about this I mean he could stay
quiet and spend his money on who cares I
think he would come out unless there was
a specific absolutely disagree my point
is Elon Musk clearly cares more about
his ideological position than the money
whereas I think he also cares about
Legacy his own I completely agree and so
his position is Free Speech matters the
woke mind virus is destru and I'm not
going to sacrifice the world for a
paycheck especially it's easy to say
when you're the richest guy on the
planet but I don't think it has to be a
paycheck right like what is his longterm
this has gained him so much influence
among conservative or moderate people
like he could have been a silent
billionaire just doing whatever he
wanted with his cars and his a million
children he was never a silent
billionaire though he was loud and proud
but he he could have been if he wanted
to he has chosen to continue to push
down this path because he wants to be in
the public eye that's not ideological
position there might be a counter to
that though like with Tesla he was able
to sell it because he was not a you know
silent person it was the first time it
worked for him but that wouldn't existed
if he wasn't loud because he was loud
and got everyone to invest in it I know
he knows that having social influence is
really important it is the ultimate
social currency right now in which case
he should have said I'm sorry to the
advertisers because then this unless he
doesn't think it's long IDE logical
position is more important to him yeah
he's consistent Elon clearly is a guy
who cares about ideological issues yeah
my point is that I think he realizes the
issues that he's promoting right now and
maybe he feels them personally I have no
reason to doubt his authenticity he
realizes that it resonates with the
American public in a way and the
international public people feel like
they are being manipulated by big
corporations that don't represent their
values and then you have this guy saying
I'm going to be open and speak out about
this but that's not a financial
incentive I never said it
hadal incentive yeah well it's it's I I
I just I think it's ideological there
there's there's no I look the way he
said go f yourself it's clearly an
emotional reaction oh yeah especially
when he said he's like you know if if x
ceases to be a company then you see that
thing we said he's like if if you know
if they break us and ruin us then at
least people will know who did it like
he said it in this really weird way
you're like but if it wasn't if it was
planned I'm not saying it was does that
make it less authentic like if he had
gone on there being like I know I'm
going to find a way to just say go after
yourself to the advertisers want to go
on this thing I do sort of agree with
Tim that he does fly by the seat of his
pants time seems at least seems like it
one thing you can say though about
platforms where you could say oh who
cares they can just get any
advertisement that is the sign that a
platform is sort of you go this is sort
of an off the beaten path platform as
you start seeing dick enlargement pills
and like all that sort of stuff so if
you went on Twitter and it was all those
kind of advertisers it would take away
from its like legitimacy as a town but
it is a lot of chichin Chong have weird
everybody that I've never seen that I am
90% Che honestly I've seen people say
all the time they go my whole thing is
chich and Chong and I've all I see is is
I see that doctor with the gooey thing
you see that one it has like 200 million
impressions must be spending Millions
what is he selling I don't know I've
been I click on the website to and it's
like honestly I think he's just saying
that it's good to use like MCT oil or
stuff I don't even I think I know what
you're talking about is that the one
where he says don't put creaming your
coffee yes and then I'm like and and
then I went on the website to try and
but like every one of their ads has
they're not selling anything 100 million
impressions they're spending so much
money and I specifically I'm like all
right let's see what this does just
because I want to know I couldn't even
figure out what this yeah I watched this
video for like 10 minutes and I'm like
okay well that was a fun podcast I guess
I
don't yeah but I don't know okay cool oh
for the record I cannot confirm at all
that black rock has any money in spin I
can't anywhere going it's been for about
10 minutes yeah thanks but that that guy
was saying you're right he's like he's
like you want to have uh you want to
have uh no I think he was saying MCT was
bad wasn't he I don't know I I can't
figure it out no he said coconut is good
or maybe coconut I don't I don't know
but they
don't coconut Lobby he's just out there
like you guys should know about this
it's like some Doctor Who has just tons
of money but like I can't tell what he
even sells but they're spending so much
money on ads I think the problem they're
going through we went through this at
Minds is that these investors come in
with huge amounts of money and they say
I want x amount of Impressions over this
much time and then they put it all the
money in so it goes to the front and
keeps getting recycled and it's like
really bad for the the platform cuz you
don't want people to get saturated with
the same ad over and over I guess yeah I
guess that's happening cuz you guys all
see the same ads and I see the same ads
but they're different I haven't seen
either one of these ads that help at all
Chong is out there man that gu got the
deepest pocket in Hollywood what are
they advertising what is
cies CBD gummies he's just advertising
getting high alter in lifestyle he's not
saying like any specific brand he
doesn't have choice I got to say though
uh he's just saying smart them up man
Instagram ads infinitely better than
than x I'm not trying to be a dick I
like X but I go on Instagram and it's
like they have they have shirt that you
would wear pictures of me wearing the
shirts being like know you're wearing
the shirts they get me too Instagram is
pretty good at that you're just like ass
sh that you were just imagining in your
mind do you think it's because they have
the shop feature now that they were able
to more seriously refine their data yeah
if you buy one thing get they know what
you like immediately they might have a
deal withon like they could have deals
like Zuckerberg is a psychology he's did
a Psychology major in college I'm pretty
sure they're obsessed with tracking you
and getting all they're tracking you
and it shows in the ads they're
successful but like at what cost
Facebook was like in their terms of
service if you opened Facebook on any
tab they could read every other tab you
had open even in different Windows which
is like Facebook it starts drizzling out
they're pitching you umbrellas like they
are on it yeah yo crazy story is that we
went to I went to a Walmart once this is
like five years ago and we are walking
down the middle of one of the aisles and
they had one of those things set up in
the middle of the aisle which a bunch of
TVs and it said special on sale 397 TVs
and I was like I didn't think twice I
was like oh okay you know maybe we get
one of these and then we we we leave I
go home sit down on my computer and
there's an ad for that exact photo that
happens a lot and I was like on the
sidebar and I was like wait what like it
wasn't just a photo at a Walmart it may
have been but it was identical to the
like the aisles were the same I was like
it may actually be that Walmart has a
crew member take a photo or they hear
your words that's the other part like
I'll just say then I'll see penis
reduction pills and I was just talking
about probably the GPS on the phone and
it's possible I don't know if they do
this but imagine it's a very smart thing
to do Walmart says hey this morning team
leag take a picture of your TVs because
we're doing an ad campaign they go okay
and then take a picture upload it and
then the Walmart team on Facebook has
Regional advertisements with those
photos so when my phone aligns with the
GPS Facebook serves me the ad for that
region at that Walmart of the photo of
the exact TVs I was looking at in
marketing they want to show you the same
ad eight times to get you to buy it
there's a number eight I think it's
eight could be a different number at
this point and so what they'll do
probably is they're tracking what ads
are at what stores and if you go to that
store by GPS then they want to serve you
that ad again and get you to buy that
thing yeah insid I mean you call it
Insidious it's really dirty if people
don't know what's happening to them bro
it's it's crazy how I mean yo you you
guys want to hear something crazy yeah
so when we went and got the nth time
they showed you that thong yeah I just
had to buy it I was like I was like I
can't stop I hit the button and it true
no uh uh so we went to I went to Tiana
to get medical treatment because I was
having hip problems and so we did this
whole thing at the uh uh cellular
performance Institute got stem cells and
they said one of the things you can't do
is you can't do ice ice uh uh uh uh what
what are they called ice baths or
whatever I bath yeah is that what it's
called you can't for three months
because it kills the stem cells for
three months and no saunas take it easy
start exercising slowly and I'm like
okay cool no problem how are you going
to f life but yo as soon as the 3 months
were up guess what Instagram sent me an
ad
four an ice bath oh no exactly at the 3
month Mark not exactly like within like
a week of it and I'm like wait wait
account for delivery I I've never done
this stuff I've never done an ice bath
I've never done any of that ice skate
and all of a sudden I'm getting ads for
it and I'm like I didn't even Google
search
this I bought one yeah yeah yeah I B I
bought it it's automatic it
chills you go on your phone you press
the button it chills the water and
spinning it around and then once you're
done working out you die in and I ended
up buying it you got an ice paath it's
on its way oh nice they got me I don't
understand dude they got me junor I
don't know man maybe it's you know what
it is it's probably not as crazy as you
think I follow Joe Rogan yeah for sure
you follow probably so many like and
they're like everybody who follows these
guys has heard about this and they're
probably going to buy it if we send it
to them it's that simple and Luke goes n
his house they're also putting you in
Upper Echelon of money and they're not
sending everyone like here buy this
$5,000 ice bath that's getting served to
very few people it could hot tub ant I
bath it's got a pump that you you can
like with an app set the temperature you
know what you're on you're on the sucker
list oh yeah they're like the whale
category like these Mor will spend
anything definitely they got me though
change our lives man thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 pm and become a member
over at
timcast.net thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next
time